foreign
what's up Eric how we doing hi there
David how are you I'm I'm John I'm I'm
sitting in for Dave today but I'm doing
great how are you
um good to hear John um I want to let
you know I'm a big fan of your show I
like your show and I've been following
your advice
um long story short I don't want to get
in with the full scenario if we need to
do that and I'll need to sit with an
advisor but I'm low income and I filed
for bankruptcy about three years ago
which I know you're against that but it
was the best thing that could happen to
me because I learned a financial lesson
I
um as a result of being low income do
not want to own a car I do not want to
lease the car and that is completely off
the table and I received professional
advice against doing that and I'm fully
agreeing with that I also agree with
Dave's advice about not bothering with
credit cards because that's off the
table what I was advised to do was to
rent a car from Enterprise when you need
it because my insurer and my other
advisors told me you want to be the type
of person that you want to use the car
when the car is done you hand it over
and say it's your problem now you want
to take the damage waiver out and
everything I normally advise against
that but in your case I'm for it however
as you know for the those car rental
places it contradicts Dave's advice and
you need a credit card to rent from them
and I don't want a credit card is there
any tactic or way of advisement get
around it because I'm bankrupt and it
would cost me more for a credit card
obviously to get the bankrupt card that
I don't want to begin with then it would
be worth but it's more feasible to rent
the car what do I do because it
contradicts sure sure let me tell you
this first
um
you've been through hell and back
haven't you
don't worry so what I want to tell you
is just
guide a guy friend to friend now
I'm glad you're back and you've been
through it
and you've got more
advice and people jawing at you and
people coming after you it's been a
rough season and I want you to know I'm
grateful for your call and I'm grateful
for these boundaries you're putting in
place in your life
um there's gonna come I'm grateful that
you've been able to take my call because
I haven't been able to get through to
the show and today I just decide
randomly I'll try it luckily I got
through I'm more grateful that you took
the call well that's that's awesome
um
so there's there's long story short I
travel all over the country I'm I'm gone
probably a week and a half sometimes two
weeks a month
I rent cars all over the nation and I
don't have a credit card
I use my debit card
can you okay I do have
um on on the on the debit card that I
travel with I do have space and so I am
fortunate that if they put a 300 hold or
whatever that's okay I'm okay with that
I know not everybody's in that situation
okay
um I want to go back before and I by the
way and I've also run into trouble I've
I've just I I was just telling Jade off
air we were talking about this and I
said I one time was sitting at a at a
car rental counter in Dallas Texas and I
looked at the person working and I said
can you please figure out a way that I
can give you my money I'm trying to pay
you and she would it was just it was
such a mess I ended up having to leave
and I had to go to another counter they
took my money right away and had me in a
car within two minutes and then we're
out the door
that said I really want to challenge the
wisdom and again you've got people
working with you and you've you and I
have known each other for 90 seconds now
I want to challenge the wisdom
that you are taking a very expensive way
to get yourself around
and when I want to go expensive I like
to go luxury because it's only
occasional Eric are you still walking
through the bankruptcy or is it complete
like was it chapter seven it's finalized
to chapter seven it's finalized good
done it's gone and I'm proud of it I
wouldn't want to do it any other way
okay basically and I'm attached only and
so where are you at now with your income
I'm just low income I'm in housing type
situation okay how much or if you know
if you don't feel comfortable saying it
that's fine but I'd like to be able to
help you as accurately as possible
how much um what do you need to know I
wanted to know what you're earning a
month because I want to find out your
debt is gone you know everything's been
liquidated I want to know what you're
left with and kind of what your plan
going forward is because I agree with
John renting cars is not sustainable
you're going to spend more on the long
haul you can get a cash car at some
point not today but we want to get you
on a plan that's going to be sustainable
and you keep referring to yourself as
low income as though it's an identity I
want to disagree with that's not who you
are brother that's where you find
yourself right now that's not who you
are yeah okay yeah um basically I get
800 a month and my portion of rent is
300 and then housing's portion
um and basically the rest of the money
is goes on whatever else in the
necessary food groceries training my
Transit card things like that it's
basically gone by the time it makes
there after the bills are you on
disability are you unable to work
um it's a long story but yes I don't
want to get into that situation on the
air if you want to speak with me about
it on a more or connect me with an
advisor I can get into that portion but
yes we definitely want to do that we
definitely want to get you connected
with somebody that you can help you
financially and I'm going to have Austin
pick up afterwards because there's a lot
more to this and um and I agree but I
just you know it's time constraining for
the show I'm absolutely right to the
point with that going on
I mean then that's this is the fact what
what John said you're going to run into
an issue with that because when you do
use a debit card they're saying hey yeah
we'll do this but your liability to us
so they're going to charge a lot more on
your card they're going to put those
holds on there
um if you're going from place to place
sometimes they'll even say like you've
got to show us your ticket if you're
flying somewhere your ticket here and
your ticket returning like they they do
put they make it hard for people who
honestly just want to pay cash for
things
they do and so in your situation where
your income is so limited I don't
believe that this is the best possible
thing for you long term but in the short
term do know that you are going to run
into those problems and I know you
mentioned you do like to do Luxury when
you do do it it it's not a season for
luxury right now
um I totally get that sentiment and that
feeling that's just not the season
you're in right now
um and here's the thing Jay this is the
choice I made kind of like what if I've
got a diet restriction I'm always doing
these weird diets and I go to your you
and Sam's house for dinner I'm not gonna
impose that on you guys I get to make
choices about what I mean because it's
that's on me yeah so when I go to a
rental car counter I'm not mad at them
they're making my life hard but I chose
this this no credit live that's right
and so be it man I'm not gonna lose
sleep because y'all don't want my
business right